we have gotten a glimpse of what the
offseason could be like before free
agency begins with no scouting combine
there could be some days where there
isn't a lot going on and unfortunately
the one big story that is filling the
void is not a good story although it
seems like the seahawks have finally
realized that there was no option for
them but to sever ties with the
individual who is at the heart of the
story chad wheeler a backup offensive
tackle for the seahawks made news
recently because he was arrested and he
was actually jailed over the weekend on
suspicion of domestic violence the
details are over the top shocking i
don't know how it's only suspicion of
domestic violence it should be attempted
murder i'm not going to get into the
details but
it's easy to find out more about the
story and
it felt like initially curtis crabtree
or works or overnight shift wrote the
first story that we had on it and then i
saw his name trending on twitter and i
started looking into a little bit more
it's like oh my god this is horrible and
no one's writing about it no one's
talking about it i guess it's because
he's not a star player but it seemed to
catch
more and more attention as the day
unfolded shireen and the seahawks wanted
to
i think just do nothing because he's due
to become a restricted free agent he is
a restricted free agent excuse me if you
don't tender an offer to him he just
becomes a free agent and he leaves and
you're done with him and you never have
to do anything
that seemed to be what they were going
to do and they initiated they issued a
statement initially to that effect but
they have since actually waived him so
they have washed their hands of him the
nfl has simply said they're reviewing
the situation under the personal conduct
policy wheeler himself has issued a
statement saying that he's walking away
from football and he's going to get the
help that he needs apparently there's a
bipolar disorder at play here but
regardless
shocking over-the-top incident of
domestic violence
and
hey if if
if they say the nfl
is a privilege not a right then the
first guys that have to be stripped of
that privilege are guys that engage in
this kind of behavior period yeah
mike i'm going to go out on a limb and
say no one's going to pick this guy off
of way up off of waivers tomorrow and
that he is going to be a restrictive
free agent who is not going to be signed
i think his nfl career is over as it
should be and frankly i didn't know
chad wheeler i had to look him up and
then i when i saw i played with the
giants in 2018 2017 and 2018 i was like
oh yeah chad reader he started a bunch
of games for the giants at tackle and
and it kind of clicks but yeah he's a
no-name guy but when you do something
like this mike that's so horrific it's
just awful to to read um and just his
career should be over
yeah and
the only thing that bothers me about
that isn't the fact that his career is
over it's the reality
that
if he were
a perennial pro bowler if he were an
all-pro if he'd been a first-round pick
this year
that's when
people start getting second chances at
the expense of someone else's first
chance i always try to point that out
when someone who's done something they
shouldn't have done gets their second
chance somebody who's never done
anything wrong ends up losing his chance
because it's a zero-sum game when you
talk about roster size but that's the
one thing that bothers you about sports
of all kind at every level
the better you are
the more likely you are
to get a second chance and
for chad wheeler
it's a no-brainer no second chance
you're gone uh you're at the bottom of
the roster you're gone we've got zero
tolerance for guys at the bottom of the
roster who do things they shouldn't do
and again it's it's good that the
seahawks got to the right place i'd like
to see the nfl make a stronger statement
about it i think one of the other
reasons that people were so quiet about
it throughout the course of the day
because it's not a big name player
you you make it a bigger story by doing
something about it i'm not saying that's
right or wrong but i'm trying to
understand why it just kind of
percolated in plain sight and it reached
boyle because of people who caught wind
of it
among the fan bases saying
what the hell's going on here they've
they've suspended guys like ezekiel
elliott who was never even arrested for
anything and he got suspended six games
so uh there was a sense of a double
standard at play and and look i just
think that that the nfl and the seahawks
were hoping that it just would go by
unnoticed and they wouldn't have to deal
with it at all and just be done with the
guy well they're done with him the nfl's
done with him and we're done with him
hopefully we won't have to mention his
name ever again
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports